the jurogan experience to me
khabib is one of the scariest tools oh
yeah because
he's beating you down he's not only
beating you not he's
breaking you mentally and for me that is
worse than anything for me is the
scariest one pound for pound
cabbage is he the guy that you would
come back for
i would have like would have now it's
all over now you're done
that's it i've done this three years ago
hey gsp it's dana white no listen i
gotta fight for you
now i'm gonna explain to you if he if he
wants me to fight
he needs to to do it like that's how he
needs to do it
he needs to hide himself wait that i'm
in a gym training
papa when i was in early with freddie
roach hitting the pads and
getting back because i haven't done this
it's because kovit everything is closing
in montreal right but i went back and
now i found i found that
found my mechanic back men and when you
hit when you train in
mixed martial art and combat sport you
become a different person you know
and tata and freddie look look at me
like he's like
george you you get the hitch back i'm
like ah
stop saying that and if dana white would
walk in
right now in the gym in between round i
would sang the contract in a
blink of an eye but then after i go back
home
go back in my troll in my comfort and
i'm like hell
no there you are working with freddie
yeah and i'm and people are like hey are
you
practicing left-handed i always been uh
uh both yeah i like how freddy has a
[ __ ] he's got a mask on his chin
what's that protection freddy
take that stupid goddamn thing off
and you know i'm i'm left-handed because
i always been left-handed
it was a card that a secret card that i
kept in my uh in my arsenal that i if i
would have need to use it
which yes i was going to switch perhaps
with bisping in the in the fourth round
and
oh really yes so you're more comfortable
left-handed
no more comfortable in the southpaw no
i'm i'm
i would say i've started a more
comfortable as
a regular stand but because i do karate
i always if you ask if you ask my
coaches everybody knows
but i always fight one side because i
believe it's a secret card that i
that you can pull off and and surprise
everybody
but you don't show your hand when you
play card you only show what you need
to show to win the fight well you see
that with wonder boy
like wonder boy he's right-handed but he
fights in my opinion at his best when
he's right leg forward
because he throws front leg kicks yes
like that's one of the things he does
like he oftentimes will
he'll switch back and forth fluidly
don't get me wrong he can fight
well from both stances yes but when he's
right leg forward you see a lot of those
front leg kicks and that that's some of
the most difficult [ __ ] to get through
with that guy
right yeah there's guys that has
a lot of problems finding a support yes
there's guys like this switch is
everything yes it can change
everything yeah so that that's why it
was for me a car a secret car that i
kept
in case you know like like i i i would i
would need it
but unfortunately for me like bisping
was very good with sulphurs
as well he he knocked out like rule of
croco
perhaps is one of these things that i
should have used earlier in my career
unfortunately and i did not
unfortunately you're one of the greatest
of all time how about relax i i'm very
i'm very critic about myself joe and and
uh yeah
yeah it always can be better right but
that's always
one of the reasons why champions are
champions is that they are self-critical
that's what makes if you just think
everything you do is amazing and you
don't have any room for improvement
i think some of the reason why champions
become champions is this
terrible discomfort of like analyzing
themselves and like not liking certain
aspects of what they're doing
finding flaws in their technique or
watching a tape i shouldn't have got hit
with that why is that like ah
you get crazy and angry and then you
train harder the people that are
self-satisfied they're like really
easily satisfied with their with their
work they never reach the level of
champion
because they don't feel that horrible
discomfort when you're looking at
yourself and you don't like what you see
yeah and my friend city fletcher says
says that
shout out to ct i love that dude he's
the man iron addicts for life
big inspiration i love him and he says
to me when the day that you're satisfied
choose to do something else yeah and
it's a little bit
what happened to me in fighting i made
peace with it i uh
like i i wanted to come back for khabib
um because it was so you know
for a fighter the scariest thing
sometimes is the most exciting thing to
do and
it's a problem that never been solved
before but to come back for another
guy and fight for another title if i win
it's gonna be another one after and
another one and another one
and i'm gonna turn 40 years old and
i hate to admit it joe and i refuse to
accept it but
and sometimes i think so i think my best
years might be behind me
well listen you're right oh i just said
okay
it's something okay i'm not done
well dana you're hearing him right now
no no no no no no no no no no no no
let's make it happen but khabib has done
as well and khabib is uh what is he 32
i i think khabib is 32 or 33. that's
right so he's in his athletic prime how
old this could be
find out how old khabib is i believe
he's either 32 or 33. yeah but it's
different for everybody some people will
reach their prime
at 25 some people like 22 some people at
35
you know look at look at boevitch he's
incredible
38 years old and he's dominating the
light heavyweight division
i think for khabib it was also a promise
that he made to his mother
and i think that's where it lies when
his father died he told his mother this
is gonna be the last fight and then he
fought justin gaichy yeah and he said
that's it
and i understand why because fighting
takes a lot out of you and takes a lot
of out
of the people who loves you yeah because
you play basketball you play baseball
you don't play fighting
and the out the outcome of a failure
it's could be very very bad
you know what i mean it's not like yeah
you you lose a game of basketball or
something like that you lose a fight
it can have huge repair question
on your your health your well-being but
also your income
and your family and everything sure like
the like stipe's loss to in ghana when
you watch that loss that
that's a horrible price that he paid
when he got knocked out
and you see him out cold and francis
hits him with that hammer fist after
all he cared him with the left hook
that's a horrible place to be
if that's your child you think of
khabib's mother looking at him and
if that's your child that's a terrible
thing to watch that's right and but
i think psychology psychologically for a
fighter
it's hard to come back from a ki from a
knockout
but it's probably harder to come back
from
a fight where you've been dominated
and broken for five round like we're
you clearly know that you did not belong
there with that
you know like like khabib's that's his
style that's why i'm saying he's the
scariest guy right
he can knock you out submit you but he's
get if he wins the fight it's not it's
very less likely it's going to be on a
on a punch that clips you it can happen
but it's going to be on a very dominant
performance he's going to maul you
exactly catch new episodes of the joe
rogan experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog
jre videos on spotify including clips
easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify
app go to spotify now to get this full
episode of the joe rogan experience